welcome back true news a lot of people
sitting there wondering you know
where is that go after ricky gervais
nowhere stop
no oh carry on you know i mean keep
churning out the quality content uh
you've not seen the video yet if you're
new here you may think this absolutely
[__] me but
subscribe now subscribe now
this over their subscribe shoulders
going should you really be watching that
just let them subscribe mum
that man looks like he's resting on his
laurels yes i am resting on my [__]
laurels
better than all of the uk podcasters
proportionally made a [__] new show
that
shit's on pewdiepie what you surprise oh
you can't tell
i've just said it just write the video
do whatever you want i don't give a [__]
it's all engaged best out youtuber in
the uk you're looking at him [__]
everyone else
different did i go too far no i don't
think so different though
very different
[Music]
so a while back i got a dm on instagram
linking me to the instagram page of this
woman terry murray not that woman that's
an advert
you did not [__] her as far as we know
you might know the other one so this is
them on a night out
on the instagram profile which is now
private annoyingly
she shared a picture i think a day later
and i want to say along the lines of
something with wearing his shirt
saying this one yeah ryan it looks much
better on me than the bedroom floor so
anyway
uh nine months later this girl had a had
a baby
supposedly and she believes that he's
the father i was linked to
instagram stories saying that
conversation between these two where
she's saying look it's yours he's going
you're mad [__]
nice you're mad as a box of frogs yeah
the [__] with the matter is he's denying
it does the baby look like him
a little bit i mean it doesn't it looks
like every caucasian male
in ireland or doesn't it can't deny it
or england it's white
she has a good look at lass there she is
that was the view i mean kinda can't
deny now my big question who took the
picture if he wasn't there with her
if you look very far in the background
if we zoom in here that's conor mcgregor
on a boat can you move down a bit sure
people have been complaining about me
uh looking at women's asses objectifying
them into those people i say get off the
[__]
video if you don't like your little
[__] she said
i don't want his money no i just want to
yeah yeah
me neither i just want to prove he is
clauder
she given her an irish flow down yeah it
doesn't look like me oh it's
got an irish name so what do you call it
it's got your hat
you're calling her liar this is when he
went to see the grand national and there
was a lot of riding done that night
am i right probably i mean jockeys do
often ride home yeah
moving up last may terry filed an
initial inquiry form for child
maintenance but she didn't want his
money
but never mind naming mcgregor as the
respondent
in july she got two more forms to fill
in and has yet to do so
teresh says she's decided to tell her
story she felt she had nowhere else to
turn
she said i'm still thinking i shouldn't
do this it is wrong but it's got to the
point i'm living with my mum
on my own with no job with a baby i'm
struggling it's harder than i thought it
was
oh you do feel sorry for other ones you
do if you [__] a guy on a night out
let's just say it's any random guy right
i mean we've all done it
and you get pregnant and you decide to
be
right are you at that point making a
judgment call
for your own life that you then have to
live with or just because you want to
keep the baby
should the guy then be forced to be
in the baby's life be the dad yeah if he
made the decision to have sex with her
then you have to be willing to go with
every outcome of that do the crime do
the time i mean
it's not really a crime and it's not
really the time it's not mine i'd say if
you're willing to have sex
be willing to have a child you hear that
lads
judge mckenna has ruled in favor of
terry murray if in fact is his baby
human life is a serious thing what
you're thinking
you're thinking that he doesn't want to
get caught surely if conor mcgregor is
the dad of a child
he wants to know one thing she said here
is she wanted to sort it out privately
right and i don't know why he let me
come to this i was notified of this
months ago so i'm sure if i was notified
about it
months ago he was notified about it
right she he has had the chance to come
and do a dna
test however i don't recommend it this
picture isn't
good he was just helping look at where
his hand is
naughty notorious i'm only going to say
this and i think this is what we will
all take from this story you look great
in that [__] can i just hear connor if
you're watching
[__] love that [__] who would you say
are the most famous pop star slash
athlete men on the planet you see
ronaldo would be one of them lebron
james
james is one and mcgregor i'd probably
be in the top three big you're letting a
girl
take a photo like that with your hand
there i just don't think it's the
smartest thing he's ever done
but he's human boys will be boys
fighters will be fighters
conor mcgregor is a man who gets in a
cage
and beats the [__] out of other men for
a living are we
actually gonna act surprised when the
man wants to [__] women and get off his
tits no one's
a wild [__] i'll say that this
is gonna happen i mean to be fair for
someone who doesn't want the attention
she's
sure given the press a lot of shots that
was a that's when the baby's tapping
this she's she's got the baby in a
sharpshooter he put his arm around me
and walked me into the bedroom and in
the room she'd ask her a photo
he turned around and goes baby i'll give
you a whole movie
never mind a picture now
if he did actually say that that is
[__] funny if you did it you gotta
look after the baby
she let the baby in your life do you
because everyone's gonna know
yeah she's made it so public that that
child now can't go to school and go
right let's talk about our parents what
does your daddy do well my daddy's away
on an oil rig no your daddy's getting
his face beaten off
like that child will always now live
with the idea that conor mcgregor
could be the baby's father let's get
this dna test done connor come on
do the right thing the person i feel
most sorry for the baby
everyone's been asking for a football
channel
to kick off the links in the description
below if you loved all the old newcastle
rants the football hangover all of that
subscribe so you don't subscribe it's
like well what you've been asking for
then don't be a [__] hypocrite sorry
sorry please do so for those who don't
know liam neeson
said some bad [__] play the clip i'm not
going to use any names but i was aware i
came back
and she told me she had been raped as he
handled the situation of the rape in the
most extraordinary way
i asked did did she know there was no
what color were they she said
it was a black person i went up and down
areas
with the cash hoping i'd be uh
approached by somebody i'm ashamed to
say that
and i did it for maybe a week hoping
some black bastard would come out of a
pub
and have a go at me about something you
know so that i could
kill him it was horrible horrible when i
think back
that i did that and i've never admitted
that dude i'm saying it to a journalist
holy [__] i get the feeling tom bateman
doesn't quite know what to do in this
journalist is probably going ding ding
ding ding ding because the generals love
her
love a scoop he wanted to basically to
boil it down he wanted to kill
or injure a black person because he
heard that one of his friends was raped
by
a black person i don't think a racist
person would come out and say
yeah i can't believe i had that thought
how horrible i should never have thought
that
if they still held those views so in
that respect i don't believe liam neeson
is a racist and i
hope that what he's come out and said
will then
encourage others to look at their own
views and think well is there any logic
and what i'm thinking because
one of my friends had a bad experience
with someone who was
this religion or that color of skins
therefore i tore everyone with the same
brush
i hope that that's what comes of it but
that isn't always how people are going
to take this
and that's why liam neeson has to be at
his age
in his position it's much more sensible
with the [__] he comes out with in
admitting
that he had a racist thought he's then
made the whole uh black community who
happen to know of him and be
fans of his and i'm sure there's plenty
of them because he makes some [__]
good movies
someone that they look up they wouldn't
admire would have wanted to do something
like that to them just because of the
color of their skin
they don't need to know that you you
should be smart enough at this point to
hold back
we had your vase on yeah when javier
said when i do a joke
it's [__] bulletproof well when you
talk about race it better be bulletproof
if this man
mr liam neeson felt bulletproof enough
to be able to say that
he probably believes that he is trying
to help in some way
or in some way be a catalyst for an idea
of change
after he'd stated the initial views
about black people and how he felt
at that moment he should have dug deep
and and
and poured his heart on i can't believe
i thought that was a terrible thing
i should never have thought that what a
stupid thing to think and that's why
everyone now
you know you can't go out there and
think these things about the killer
color of someone's skin
but he didn't i watched an interview
with him a day or two later with a black
woman
who gave him the forum gave him the
platform to talk
and he still didn't nip it in the bud
and i i'm watching him thinking don't
think you're a bad guy but
man you might not be the brightest i
thought he was a lot smarter than what
he was he
he leaves himself wide open to be shot
in it
in a second interview i'm thinking you
[__] the first one if someone wanted
to annihilate him in an interview
if he sat here in front of me he'd need
more than a set of skills i'd [__]
own the [__]
if he had wrapped it off with a nice
little bow which is very difficult story
to do because actually there's so many
different threads there you can't really
wrap that story up nicely
there are a lot of people who would have
taken this story and run with it
no matter how he told the story agreed
agreed in future this [__] needs
to think before he speaks
i don't know if this [__] is
going to be thinking or speaking much
more in the future
just rehearse the lanes leo i was
interested in what john barnes said i
think john barnes went a little far
saying he deserves a medal but i was
interested to see that john barnes was
basically saying this man is trying to
start a dialogue and we are deliberately
misinterpreting what he's saying
john john bonds he knows liam neeson is
not meaning to make things worse and
that he's trying to admit
a wrongdoing in order to encourage
people to not do the same thing
however i can't sit there and be like
what he said was fine because it wasn't
and and credit to john bonds for being a
good block to speak on this sort of
thing but i'm not going to see deserves
a [__] medal for it over the last
week emiliano saleh you know the
footballer in france
who'd taken the plane and sadly died in
a plane crash
what i have found difficult the amount
of people who paid no attention to him
before
then hashtagging things like r.i.p
and tragic what has happened i
understand people can be sad about
things i'm not trying to take away from
that
but what does annoy me is when people
who are never paid attention to it in
the first place
all these kind of things you know they
want to be those guys who go this is
tragic we could definitely get some
followers off this
this is really [__] sad rrp seller
why is it that your news
organization and the individuals within
your news organization go
that's getting a lot of clicks we should
r.i.p that like that
to me is sick it's not a happy week this
is it
i feel like the news cycle goes up and
down and this will be
miserable this one sorry everyone life
is full of peaks and troughs
you don't know you're on a peak until
you're coming down you don't know you're
in a trough until you're coming out do
you know who said that david brent
gervais played him we even just had a
podcast with him so our week was good
hashtag respect the podcast yeah in more
positive news
right search or kelly how is this going
to be positive [__] miserable
how is this gonna be so [__]
miserable oh kelly's studio looks
[__] incredible that's because it's
not a studio laurence it's a sex den
anyone who's seen the documentary i've
already seen the first two episodes but
holy
[__] hell have you seen the first
time pretty damning isn't it yeah is an
abusive person if one or two people come
forward you can argue that
man there is an army of women there just
being like
he destroyed me tmz have got this to say
oh kelly wants back into his studio and
he wants to work
late night hours i'm sorry our richard
is it it's robert i'm i'm sorry ricky
the reason you're on curfew is because
you're not allowed to do things at night
time can i just say this
for a recording studio there's not much
recording stuff not literally there's
like
a piano there just in case the feds come
yeah do you hear that what is that
that's police
dog go over to the piano i don't see
nothing wrong
honestly wrong sing along now he's being
asked to
have his studio available to him in the
late night hours
because apparently they've said he has
to be out by five or whatever yeah
five p.m he's got it from nine don't get
creative and totally
it's also the audacity that when you're
being accused of such serious things
and you look pretty much bank to rights
you're going i still need to be able to
write my
songs it's like no one you do not
understand now
you are [__] like forever when
everyone finds out the
farmer has been [__] in the milk
they don't want the milk no more
remember
michael jackson got accused a lot he one
hit boom back on top
it annoys me like your world you know
you did
everything stop singing him that's
probably the worst thing you could do
tell me about ja rule uh ja rules [__]
because jar rule was part of the
con which was firefest and it was an
island full of middle class
um rich people who have been tricked by
this guy because of youtube has taken
money to say come and come to our party
guys
and famous models i didn't get that
money no one wants to go to an island
alone with you
billy mcfarland and jar rule are gonna
have to scrounge together about three
million to pay back an investment
company
that got screwed so basically all the
people now i'm pretty sure this guy knew
this
this this uh being the final guy
mcfarland's the little [__] who
[__] everyone
he knew basically that at some point
people would come running for him and he
knew that if he attached himself someone
big then that big person would likely
take some of the forward
there's a word for people like jar rule
here lightning rod you you hold them up
the lightning hits them and you just
walk gone on but having said that
what was your favorite song ironically
mine was with r kelly
which one oh oh oh oh oh
wonderful do everybody though living it
up what yeah
that in a bar if you i do
and everyone in the bar would go oh this
is so good
because it was a banger the media says
jones made his fortune on sandy hook
he's talking about everything
i'm sick of talking about san diego you
would be sick of talking about san diego
because you accused the people involved
in the deaths of their children as being
actors so you probably don't want to
bring that up do you
alex uh plungers are even they're like
because i'm clear to fire dude jesus who
you hate so much said
jesus told me to destroy joe rogan jesus
told me destroy joe rogan
sounds like a classic jesus thing to say
he told me the same thing he said start
your own podcast
right yeah go after him jesus told me to
go and get lunch see joe
you're in the pretend hollywood world
i'm in the big boy world that's what all
the big boys say
welcome to the big boy world i know when
i'm dealing with a informed adult that's
usually the terminology that they use
guys we are here for this meeting today
can i just say this is a big boy meeting
for everyone in here yeah big boy
big boy's only at this table because
this is a big boy table
him because if he destroys rogan then i
can just assume position ah
true geordie the real winner you want to
be friends with alex jones no
you sick [__] i would pay good money to
watch joe rogan
in real life kick alex jones in the gut
watch him on the floor just holding it
and then
george just puts their arms around his
throat yeah talks about god what are you
going to destroy [__]
what you doing what are you doing you're
going to do nothing abducted in plain
sight
have you seen that documentary on
netflix no i sort of skipped over it
because it seemed a little bit [__] but
it looked
interesting a dad they like sort of live
next door like they're sort of neighbors
type [__] pops around
and leaves a little fruit basket oh
spent a bit time with the neighbors
lately had a good time
just to make the neighbors really love
him so the whole time he's got his eyes
on the daughter who's like
12 or something like that right so the
way he finds to get in the family and
make sure that he's got access to the
kid at all times as he makes her parents
fall in love with him he has a gay
relationship with the dad
and he [__] the wife and then
eventually he [__] the daughter as well
it was mental
but the way he gets the daughter to not
unravel and admit what's going
on as he plays our recordings of his
voice that's being all distorted and
convinces our in some caravan or
whatever
it's an alien that she's uh it's aliens
and
uh they've got a mission to have babies
for a alien planet that needs a baby and
she's an alien
i i've never been more gobsmacked
watching a documentary
ever i was like it's that one i i really
don't like this but i just have to show
you
i think you have a fear of hype these
videos particularly freak you out
it's not just heights you're dicing with
[__] death look at this [__]
because i know when i'm about to die i
like to make sure i've got my little
handshake
that's the last thing he might ever do
are you
mental sir honestly all it takes is for
one of those [__] pipes to be rotted
and you're dead
wow that is [__] nuts one of those
pipes oh that's bad
that is horrible that is horrible what
are you dude
dude just hide himself latch himself off
on something you know what i mean
no one's watching that watch nightscape
as he
climbs over a building attached to it
here we go brian here's an uplifting
story
for a little man in colorado oh [__] i
heard about this
colorado runner kills mountain lion with
his bare hands
after it attacks him the runner
apparently sustained serious but
non-life-threatening injuries in the
attack despite his wounds he managed to
run
out of the park and get to hospital for
treatment uh and the lion was killed
as the victim defended himself oh here
he must be a [__] this guy
in terms of wild things that happen this
man will possibly dine out on this for
the rest of his life
he's getting some [__] out of this at
least found mountain lions and
fighting all them all the time mountain
lion attacked me but i
i told him i looked at him in the eye
and i said
not today mountain lion he went wrong i
said
no i'm not ready to die today mountain
lion
you better know when you [__] with me
you [__] with the best you imagine
the mountain lion was like
world store and he was like not today
[__] because the mountain lion's
going what's this
getting him right and his mates are
going [__] it seems to be equaling
out in some way though
oh my jimmy [__] [__] hide he's
coming for us and jimmy the mountain
lion's dead
we've got hashtag rip jimmy the mountain
lion yeah
very sad this weekend uh big get on that
three slides at least three stories at
least
hello there guys my name is come to get
your plays and today
we are doing a minecraft stadium
tutorial
yes you heard right brian a minecraft
minecraft minecraft
stadium tutorial [__] me oh he's got oh
my god how is he
[Music]
[__] it oh look at that can we employ
him because
the man is showing more dedication than
most people this has to be an exo video
can i see the finished article
um episode seven this kid is stretched
out more than a netflix series episode
eight i mean what is this [__] kid
talking about for two hours in episode
14.
he says he says 13 episodes into
because minecraft building old trafford
yeah he says mix it up the lower tier
yeah yeah you still got the roof
together yeah yeah the only thing i was
dedicated on at that age was my pawn
collection
right and favoriting all the pages i've
never seen nothing like this i can't say
i've ever seen someone else show so much
dedication to something so meaningful
this this is magnificent this all looks
proportion he's even got the [__]
adidas logos in there
if you're watching this send him a pair
of boots 42.
amazing look at this if i had his
dedication i'd have 10 million
subscribers you'd have more
you would own youtube you would be
youtube the vote closes
and then i'll do download links and then
all that good jazz
jazz fan all about jazz oh wow
loves this jazz you will know brian last
week
having watched it right the super bowl
was concluded however
conclusively [__] i enjoyed it thanks mr
craft
craft crafty the guy who owns the
patriots right i wanted to give some of
the players
cigars these are celebrations this is
kraft the man who
mr kruff the guy who owns the patriots
right these cigars
50 years old this is the way that
billionaires live
i just want to know if you ever smoked a
cigar no no
why you look like the kind of guy at
some point in his life should have
smoked a cigar i'd like to try circle
yeah
should we do that something should we go
if there's a cigar guy in london
let us know we'll come along i want to
just you know taste a cigar
see what it's like i just wanted to
further demonstrate that
americans get better education than the
uk it's just mentality what education is
this kid getting that is a teacher
imagine that being your teacher how the
[__] you can concentrate she looks like
she should be in a rat video though
doesn't she
bouncing that s just a shout out to all
the pig lovers out there um pigs don't
give a [__] about you 56 year old woman
has been eaten by pigs after collapsing
in their pen she was alive at the time
russian pigs though that's upbeat um
pegasus
husband found the body oh that must have
been a [__]
oh apparently the husband had gone to
bed early the night before
as he was feeling unwell and walked to
find his wife missing
i'm starting to think a likely story
yeah um didn't think the check if your
wife was
coming to bed now check her in the
morning yeah in the morning
where where did i last see her with a
pig pen try the pig
i think you might have [__] killed it
bundle over the head
dunk her in the [__] pig pen and let
them have a go yeah i'm not
having a go at pepsi in an age when
honesty
is key right and everything you want to
see online is real
why are they doing an advert where it's
clearly not real mo salah shoots a
football through
a tire that ball's allegedly real this
ball now i think you can see is not real
that was not a realistic flight of the
ball that wasn't real
not real why not it's just not i don't
quite understand why in this generation
we believe this stuff when we when we
knew you could first do it it's this
handheld camera thing as well that they
do it pisses me off
con come and have a look at this does
this look fake you so now he does this
thing where he does a lot of kick-ups
that isn't real no that's fake
how do you know you can just tell the
ball physics there
don't forget to subscribe to the
homeless football on youtube
subscribe the kickoff yeah uh the link's
in the description below thanks for that
bit of a miserable week hopefully you'll
be blind
next week why do you keep bringing all
these miserable stories along life
it's just the way of the world out there
we'll uh we'll see you next time bye